communications uh has historically not
provided the information like that that
that web of trust to let you know should
i trust this and because of that that's
why you've got so many robo calls and
you've got spoofers and scammers and
fisheries well in fact this was a
criticism of twilio in the early days
was that people used the platform
because you gave them phone numbers and
they could burn through phone numbers
and then there was some abuse right and
you had to deal with that and that was a
hard decision for you because we don't
want to pay for the platform
and their customers but maybe they were
using them in ways that you wouldn't
want them to how did you deal with it
back in the day
and so what we what we what we did is
you know many years ago developed our
acceptable use policy and said okay here
are the ways in which we want our
technology to be used and the other ways
we don't want it to be used
and i think as a company you do have the
ability to decide what kind of customers
you want what kind of use cases you want
and
you know as long as you've got clear
rules and uh you articulate those to
customers in your ecosystem that
certainly you should be able to decide
how your technology is used
and
and that's what i think is is really
important so this world of trusted
communications to me is about building
more trust into the communication
networks of the world now we can't do
this alone because there's thousands of
carriers in the world there's all these
different handsets in the world and so
it's a really an ecosystem
uh that is that is moving along but you
know invoice for example a new protocol
called stir shaken that we have helped
uh to bring the market along with um the
carriers
has made it so that phone calls cannot
be trusted because they're digitally
signed by the company like twilio that
is initiating that phone call prior to
this
yep
exactly
exactly if
if
well well you know before all this you
know if you're i don't know verizon and
there's an incoming phone call to your
network it kind of arrives at your
boundary you have no way of knowing
if you know the phone number that it
says it's coming from is actually true
or not because the phone network itself
was an untrusted network well
i don't know how to say i don't i don't
actually know the right way to phrase it
it was actually a trusted network if you
go way back i'll give you a little
history lesson here at t ran the entire
network in the united states at one
point right then they got broken up into
baby bells and in the in the world where
everybody was a t like to be a
participant on the phone network you had
to be 18 t that was your that was your
badge right and so in that world
yeah and all the equipment sitting in
the network was 18 i mean everything was
18t and so it's just like well we don't
need trust it's trusted by default well
of course then it got broken up into the
baby bells and then the
telecommunications act of 1996 said like
oh no we're going to open up this
network and it created selects and all
this sort of stuff well you still had
all this running on top of a network
with no trust model
and then you start to see all the bad
actors popping up and people who drop
phone calls on the network and spoofing
your phone number jason and everything
else
and that's why it has gotten so messy
and so what we've been working on for
the past several years how we bring
trust back from that network and to me
that looks like when you get a text
message from your bank
it's got a padlock
and instead of saying you know plus one
four one five or if it's a short code
you know 404 or 404 whatever it's it
says
you know your bank and there's that
green padlock there that says this is
you know assured to be who they say and
you click that it says you know twilio
has verified the identity of the center
right
that's how you know you can trust that
message and if that padlock is missing
that's when you should say well i don't
know do i trust this or maybe even your
handset just says you know what there's
no powerblock i'm not going to show it
to you
that's the world that we're building
towards where every communication is
verified and you know who is sending it
you know they're authentic
and i think that will open the doors for
even more interesting things like
commerce
like buying things over communications
much more easily because if everything
is authenticated you know that it's safe
to do that
and many more interesting ways in which
we can use messaging to engage with
companies
in ways that we did not even imagine
possible
isn't that called there used to be a
name for that remember you screen your
phone calls you the answering machine
picks up and you can listen
well it's a process
yeah it's a process and these things
don't happen overnight right they take a
while it starts with people though it
really starts with uh bringing folks
together as one team
and having and building that shared
mission because like when you acquire a
company they've got their mission we've
got ours and when you bring people
together what you need to do is start to
build that shared understanding of what
we're going to do together
and every time there's an acquisition
right you know there's some there's a
press release and the ceos do a little
like press tour and they talk about this
grand vision
and you know from the outside you might
say okay well you know that's done nice
mission good job guys um but in the
reality is like inside the company you
you have to go around you have to
evangelize you have to talk to
to the teams and and you know really
sell here's what we're building and you
got to figure out a whole lot of hairy
details about how it's going to work and
you know it's it sounds good in the
press release but the reality is it's
like okay now we got you know to
integrate uh you know identity systems
and billing systems and all systems and
even just getting the email to work you
know between the the two companies i
mean these are just really you know
mundane details but it takes teams and a
lot of work to go figure out how to do
those things
and um and so you know you've got that
and but the number what the point of
really all that
so how do i create an environment where
now these teams can actually
collaborate and unlocking this vision
that we have for the company in the long
term and the reason why we're coming
together and docking these ships
together
don't you wish you could hire a ringer
to help scale out your marketing team i
know you do well with marketer hire you
can and you can do it right now marketer
hire gives you access to expert
freelancers on demand with no long-term
contracts and no risk you can hire
experienced specialists across the most
valuable marketing disciplines from paid
social and search to growth seo content
and even get a fractional cmo if you
don't need a full-time one maybe a
fractional one would work great for you
again no long-term contracts you can
cancel at any time and if it's your
first time working with freelance talent
you'll start with a no risk trial only
hire what you need and stay on budget
with hourly part-time full-time
arrangements every freelancer on market
or hire goes through a rigorous vetting
process with industry experts
freelancers from market or hire have
been hired at over 1500 companies
including top brands like netflix all
birds and lambda school you're going to
get 500 off your first hire at
marketerhire.com
twist again
marketer
m-a-r-k-e-t-e-r-h-i-r-e dot com slash
twist marketerhire.com slash twist get
that 500 right now and you'll also get a
free consultation on who to hire based
on your needs and your goals again 500
right now marketer hire.com
twist